[Musique]
les sources d'informations trop légère
dans le contexte d'un conflit de
tensions géopolitiques
s'est informé auprès de sources fiables
c'est à dire des médias des journalismes
des individus qui ont fait leurs preuves
dans la collecte de données la
vérification de ces données
donc les médias traditionnels moi ça
reste vraiment une source privilégiée
d'information
évidemment lorsqu'on est dans un
contexte de conflit ou parfois des
journalistes deviennent possibles
il ya six mois de l'ouverture de médias
traditionnels qui est beaucoup moins
importante à ce moment là on doit bien
évidemment ce s'informer auprès de ce
qu'on appelle les journalistes et
citoyens documente le confie sur place
il faut être très prudent
voir des directs qui provient
d'individus en ligne sur les médias
sociaux c'est pas du tout en gage de
véracité des filles habilité
d'authenticité encore une fois là ça
dépend vraiment de notre expérience avec
les gens qui font ce genre de direct il
ya des individus qui justement fonds qui
vont établir quelque part leur
légitimité leur crédibilité à force de
le faire à l'extérieur qu'on peut finir
par voir que quelque part le souci de
rigueur mais il est aussi beaucoup
beaucoup de
naturisme de désinformation qui peut
plus circuler notamment peut être
relayée par ce genre de deux individus
qui vont ils ont témoigné parfois avec
l'intention c'est là qu'on est dans un
contexte de désinformation il faut qu'il
ya une volonté de tromper le public
auquel on s'adresse et dieu sait que
l'histoire du 20e siècle c'est truffé
d'exemples de mise en scène qui ont été
faites pour tenter de tromper le public
auquel on s'adressait afin de réaliser
des objectifs militaires ou politiques
encore une faute prudent il faut
s'assurer que lorsqu'on consomme ce
genre d'informations là il faut faire
preuve d'un scepticisme 5 est toujours
s'assurer qu'il ya une certaine rigueur
surtout qu'on est en présence de
journalistes citoyens dont des individus
qui sont sur place n'ont pas de
formation professionnelle en journalisme
mythique partage d'informations
les différents protagonistes d'un
conflit peuvent être des sources de
désinformation encore une fois pour
faire la désinformation il doit y avoir
une volonté de tromper le public auquel
on s'adresse pour différents motifs mais
ce n'est pas d'hier que dans le conflit
craignant par exemple il peut pas y
avoir une volonté tromper de la part de
responsables ukrainiens qui voudrait par
exemple
utiliser l'information qui est falls
pour tenter de remonter le moral des
trop sur le terrain ou pour tenter de
remonter le moral la population en
célébrant par exemple l'héroïsme de ce
soldat ukrainien même style information
qui peut être partagée pourrait être
forte on peut relayer une information
de bonne foi qui a été à l'origine fait
de façon trompeuse mais qu'on ne sache
pour que cet effet de façon trompeuse
ils relayaient à son entourage à ses
réseaux et dans ce cas là on va dire
qu'on fait de la mésinformation parce
qu'on n'a pas eu la volonté de tromper
c'est clair que bien évidemment lieu des
protagonistes des étapes plus puissantes
dont beaucoup plus de moyens et la
russie connu comme étant l'un de ces
sites qui ont énormément de moyens pour
justement mettre en scène faire ses
opérations propagande pour désinformer
les différents publics auxquels elle
s'adresse c'est une c'est une expertise
qui est aussi sa source dans l'histoire
la trabi sport 25 sept rappelons-nous le
kgb qui était le service de
renseignement du de l'union soviétique
avait s'était démarqué justement pour
ces opérations d information et c'était
une expertise qui se poursuit elles
notamment dans le cadre des opérations
qui sont menées par les propagandistes
heureux
[Musique]